Wednesday afternoon android-developers
office hours hangout this is your emea
edition coming to you from Munich
Germany that's me I'm Sparky and we've
got matt and nick coming from london UK
and we're here to answer for you any
questions or address any topics of
discussion that you want to have about
developing apps for android and with
that let's see who's gonna hang out
nobody's in the Hangout crickets chirp
chirp chirp we had some technical
difficulties today so we got off to a
little bit of a late start and make it
take a little while to catch up to us
while we're waiting for some people to
join us in the Hangout perhaps we can
turn to the moderator and see what
question we said we have queued up well
I heard somebody ding did anybody come
in not yet ok I think it's been liking a
bunch of people to enjoy this and so
yeah that would be great let me let me
call up the old moderator and see what
people have asked Martin s from
Northwest UK so I guess this will be a
question for matunuck dancer list detail
page scenario in single Peyton pane mode
activity hosts the list fragment user
selects from list sure the detail
fragment be displayed by replacing the
list fragment in the same activity or
should detail a page be launched and
sewn activity a pretty classic a pretty
classic multi fragment multi-activity
question the way we usually solve this
in our application tablets is when
you're running this app on a large
format just about device like a 10 inch
tablet then we would recommend putting
two things side by side so you have your
detail in your list on the same place
and then you run that same app on a
smaller device like a phone you should
probably completely swap out the list
view for the detail view and the easiest
way to program this is to put the list
in one fragment in the detail in another
and gin
Lee speaking when you completely clear
away one set of you I and replace or
completely with another that's kind of
an activity change and that's probably
going to be the cleanest and easiest way
to do it and as I as I noted in my in my
response in the moderator I think that
by making it a new activity is going to
be the easiest way to get the right
semantics for navigation using the back
button I just want to comment on let it
go pretty much but it bounces yeah don't
have been joined in the Hangout by
Jonathan ward hello Jonathan you have
any anything on your mind about android
development well this is the first
hangout that i'm doing so i'm not sure
if my microphone is working you hear me
I'm glad you hear you Oh fantastic I
didn't have any particular question I
just wanted to join the conversation as
my first developers office hours to see
what's up oh well welcome yeah welcome
where you at way based I'm actually
based in the US huh you know then you'll
be able to get your fill of hangouts
because the mountain view team will be
having another hangout just like this
one in eight or nine hours great so so
what's uh what's on your mind where
you're developing these days well I'm
developing a music application and
actually one of the things that I'm
trying to debug today is a viewpager
seems to not update fragments when its
underlying adapter gets notified of a
data set change I don't know if you've
run into that issue hmm i generally i
generally duck the whole data set change
issue entirely by using only loaders
that's my advice and when it i seen
slowly sometimes you to make sure is
you'll adapt to returning stable IDs
because basically there's a few
optimizations in the viewpager they all
try not to reload data he thinks it's
already loaded it and I think it's the
idea it uses to work out if it's the
same page you've already loaded forget I
comment by kind of fake remember when I
was doing something Smith this landed up
having to do a little bit of trickery
around it in terms of sort of async task
kicking in but I think why it did was
using the viewholder design patterns
that kind of ensure that it would be the
viewholder that would update from the
cursor and they're not dataview sin
needed to do so that might be different
way of kind of looking at it and yeah I
know there is a lot of kind of
authorization to the Navy paper yeah if
you're if you're looking into any of
that sort of view pager fragment adapter
sort of thing definitely do be at least
passingly familiar with the fragment
samples we demos sample absences they
implement a lot of interesting fragment
behaviors in there things like a view
pager combined with a pav manager and
you know fragments in a view pager each
with its own list view each recording
its own state they have the the throttle
loader which takes a list fragment and
fills it I think it's like one row per
second or something like that and you
can just kind of get in there and see
different ways that that the Android
engineers have have implemented
activities using these different api's
so API demos definitely should be in
everybody's repertoire as a great go-to
place for reference code it's not it's
not the end all be all that is go out of
good samples in it great I see we've
been joined in the Hangout also by
Alejandro and Emile and just know by
Marcus so welcome guys
welcome to the Hangout you have any
questions about android development or
what's on your mind I just want to say I
heard you talk about the page switcher
I've actually use it for fragment I had
some problems because i actually had
fragments containing them if i had
fragments inside fragments and that's
not really supportive National Diet
acted so I ended up making like a
lightweight version of fragments which
only pretty much half of you I'm not
even a life cycle but it works pretty
well actually cool how did you hear that
oh well it's I just made them from
scratch is a pretty small class um um I
might put in up the summer at some point
Oh Oh mother it was pretty simple
classic says with a class that it's a
give them to grade it so did you did you
use any of the the android framework
source code from source side and Ray
Palmer did you hold us all yourself well
I mean this is a really small classes
like 50 lines maybe so I just pretty
much followed some concepts like how do
I think it has a disability and it has
some helper method to plate use this is
actually a view to extend its like a
custom game basically no no it's it's
more like a fireman okay what I want to
see if I can prove excellent yeah that
may purchase not that yeah that's very
cool we we love to hear what you guys do
when you when you take the framework and
run with it take it in your own
direction I so I guess some of the the
more popular places that people tend to
put up their their contributions to the
code base are in the code google com or
in github I would say is probably the
top two what do you think Nick Matt yeah
I take
github is generally pretty popular these
days yeah I think that's the one that
I've seen most of the founder source
cocaine stuck up on get up yeah I
noticed that's where where the mighty
actionbarsherlock hangs out right whilst
isn't a call Emil what's on your mind
hey uh I think he saw my question on the
moderator about excuse disappearing when
rotated oh yes I was trying to write
some code to prove that out and I didn't
really get anywhere I kind of started in
on it too late yeah I wanted to respond
again but I didn't see a way to respond
again and moderator just edited my old
common but uh yeah it's really just iPad
I mean I rotate the canvas with the
matrix and run by x axis and the text
just disappears only when it's two lines
when it's one line it works fine very
interesting it will ok I'm it more than
one line I mean to three lines problem
doesn't work either way I have no idea
why I mean I can do a were crowned by
drawn to text a big map first but it's
just bad that's kind of what canvas
drawing is though isn't it i mean what
role job but I've drawing it to a bit
not before rotating yeah I this is not
uh this is not a particular specialty of
mine so i would suggest i take take your
code fragment and and put it on stack
overflow and see what the community says
and as i said in moderator share with me
the URL and i'll try to find some type
of to dig into it myself but i would bet
you that somebody out there in the
community can answer that question way
faster than I could even get to it yeah
okay yeah I'll probably do that thanks
yeah I only lost alejandro just wanted
to say i basically to close shop hmmm
hey look at that we have a link from
github cool all right thanks Marcus if
no one else has anything that you want
to talk about right away I will go back
into the moderator and see what else
we've got queued up okay just see we're
about to say something no I'm just let
me look at the distant markets
throughout their this is in the road
passes into the cheapest comments as
well yep and very interesting I see what
you mean by being a lightweight fragment
into a lot in two lines of code huh ok
the next question you know Gonzalez from
Portugal advanced NFC support and
documentation is not the best is there
any good book to look at actually I
think I have seen a book about my right
NFC but I don't recall the title of it
maybe try looking in the Android
developers forum and see if somebody is
talking about it in their Android
developers are discussed for example I
was trying to talk in high data rate
mode with an NFC he tagged and concluded
the stack does not support this again
not really my specialty I would say if
you really want the definitive source he
sounds pretty sophisticated and i would
say maybe big in the source code it's
probably some answers in there
next can I make clickable drawables
inside textview drawable created using
HTML that image get her from images
download from the web I want to be able
to zoom the images didn't Nick didn't
you enrich talked about this last week
yeah here we go this one is this the
same one I don't think it was I thought
I cleaned it out I seem to recall your
answer voice no you can't is that right
yeah you can make the whole you can make
the whole text view clickable but you
can't really assign a separate click
region inside it but you couldn't even
try that that's nothing I've done I
think if you're going to try and do it
you'd have to wrap the image in an
a-class but then you have nothing to
kind of fix up to kotov to get clicked I
don't think you could do it it would be
cool if Google now integrated with
Google events ie who's coming to event
name read out a list of yes responses
and or show the list are Google planning
on allowing developers to produce custom
cards from the now feature that would be
a forward-looking statement about
something where nothing has been
announced and I'm afraid we can't say
anything on the topic so you take that
as neither a confirmation northern I'll
simply a lack of answer let's say one
question which is from the gfs comments
so Michael back hi Michael with your to
your following on and he says he's been
using the most excellent that's my words
not his tutorial and in on Android
training about using bitmaps and liu
caches and all that good stuff to make
sure you don't get out of memory issues
and and very Germany you noticed on the
Friday review last week put the phone
then the team members said that there's
gonna be an update co2 that class and
he's wondering if it's still recommended
to use the training class as is if
enough that's already in the works so
I'd say it's it's you know techniques
are still
and they've just been slightly kind of
improved and polished with more and if
you want to take a look at that if you
actually go to the Google i/o and
application from from this year from
2012 if you search the total Google
commerce search it for that I owed
shared iOS catv and most of the
applications been open source now and
that actually includes a lot of
improvement that that's where our team
was kind of like working on stuff and
like you know squashing bugs and I could
be improving the product so if you take
a look in IO shed you can actually get
you know an early look as it were and of
the updated versions are I'd say check
that out but you know the basic version
in the training course it's still still
out cool and we are joined by Lucas
Lucas of pattern thing i believe yep in
the one kind of on everyone see Lucas's
up patton PA TT RN is a very cool app
forgetting and very nice wallpapers for
your for your phones and tablets can you
hear me yeah okay I don't have a room
here at the office because I have to
walk around price for ya oh yeah I work
for Mozilla so i'm at the mozilla office
in London oh so all the rooms are booked
so I just got curious about the
developer office hours so yeah I'm
student hanging out you're kind of
walking out yeah walking around yet well
you make me Hildy well it's good to have
you in the Hangout yeah just here to say
hi and see what's going on so we want to
share with us a little bit of what you
do at Mozilla ok so I work on Firefox
for Android pretty much so blessed yeah
we e so the initial version of Firefox
for Android will bait was based on the
same technologies than the desktop
version so soon I don't know if you're
familiar with it it's all based stuff
but we were having a lot
of performance problems because of that
so is a very chunky library so on
devices with slow file systems the
library would just take ages to load so
on some devices we would have liked
startup times of like 30 seconds so it
was a bit ridiculous so we decided to
rewrite the the whole lab the whole
front end anyway so since October so a
month ago we released the first version
of what we call native Firefox for
Android which is in practice firefox
back end between Skico rendering engine
but with the native android front end
how do you how do you handle plug-in
compatibility so if they were written to
the dual engine you mean extensions and
stuff yeah so we are like independently
of what we're doing like Mozilla is
moving for to a more api-based kind of
thing instead of the sole charm is
called it's like overlay so overlays
like pretty much messing with the with
the UI from the add-on so you can add
menu items and stuff so we're moving
from that to a more api-based thing so
we have a JavaScript API I to add menu
items and stuff so it doesn't matter
really what kind of technology is behind
the UI so you can still do things like
add a menu item at a context menu item
all those things but through a more
controlled API so what you cannot do
anymore is to overlay stuff which is
because it's not true anymore but we
still have our support we're fine with
the firefox on the unknown droid for
example so yeah there's a bit of like a
certain amount of work to adapt add-ons
but it's not too much so yeah so so we
right now we are working on the tablet
version of Firefox for Android it will
be released very soon and also native
and stuff so it was a very good exercise
of
although responsive design stuff and
although see all the stuff that the
Android gives you so it was an
interesting thing it android is not a
small app as you can imagine so yeah
well I mean we have like nine ten
persons of the same icon everywhere
because it's kind of a kind of
ridiculous amount of assets but yeah
it's worth it just to keep it like
looking good at any time of type of
device right there's a single APK that
that single single IDK yeah right oh
yeah i'm easy oh boy london sorry who
built in London no no we are like yeah
spread out mostly within the US but will
the office in London is quite new so
we're just like 22 people in this team
here so the office opened in april so
it's what you cool in Weiss and as you
mentioned like my spare time project is
pattern which is this wallpaper app for
like that grabs all the the patterns
from color lovers if you don't know this
website it's really cool is a very nice
community in create patterns color color
palettes and stuff so so I just thought
it would be fun to have a nap put that
grabs all those patterns like it's a lot
of stuff being created every day so it's
more like more than 200,000 patterns so
it's a lot of stuff and also I wanted to
have an opportunity to use Android API
that I don't have a chance to use at
work so it's kind of a more like a
learning experience than anything else
you get to take a little vacation from a
salon run chrome fort under as you were
sexting before word with firefox is the
responsive design aspects like that he
needs done a nice job of customizing the
look and feel for different sized
devices so I've had it on my phone or my
7-inch tablet and on my 10-inch tablet
and it really kind of alters its
presentation to really take
antigen screen space I think you done
nice job there oh great thanks yeah one
thing that kind of sucks in terms of
nexus 7 specific development is that we
don't have an x86 Emma later yet for for
jellybean hmm so if yeah but if it gets
a bit on the way because it's just so
slow yeah to test up there is there any
estimate for getting like em x86 image I
think he can tell create the x86 images
okay it's not google okay yeah maybe
that's a stupid question but maybe an
obvious one like why isn't x 86 the
primary target for emulator images
because that's where developers are
anyway right I guess well the answer is
in the title regulator that you were
really we were really trying to emulate
the devices it was actually running on
so I think you know the arm-based api's
were the vast vast majority devices out
there so we will try I think I was our
primary focus to you know provide a
platform where people can develop
against what it's going to run all the
phones I think that's you know
historically where we came from I don't
know if that's going to change in the
future or what but I think that's where
we are yeah yeah yeah I kind of see the
point it's just a farm for front-end
development most of the time you don't
you don't really care about the
d'architecture you just care about
seeing how the app feels even very
quickly and having a very quick is so
nice like when you get the emulator with
an 8 x86 image it's just makes a big
difference yeah well maybe that's just
the editor video point Joe vez and in
face building tools in Eclipse yeah I
use it yeah it helps but like for things
like animations and stuff I I mean
there's a lot of like back and forth
just to see like tweaking different
properties to see how it feels yeah and
for animations I mean if you if we had a
like a quick way to like preview
animation that would be nice but so like
for now we just have to run the
application and yet go so simple detents
do tend to develop on device instead
yeah for nexus 7 it was interesting
because i didn't have any device while
writing the app so i released the tablet
version the tablet UI for pattern before
having the device and I was a bit scared
scared of like what could happen because
things like I was using the didn't you
so bad on the emulator I couldn't really
see how it worked so it was a kind of
really a big guess like that it would
work well but I wasn't sure so I was
happy that it turned out to be pretty
good but yeah each other so what tricks
you got a trickster for optimizing to
the servants you're using what the
esterday 600d p yeah yeah yeah
design-wise i think the interesting
thing about 7-inch tablets is it on i
think it's a type of form factor that is
unique in the sense that in portrait and
landscape it behaves very differently
it's different than tablets that you
have a lot of space on both orientations
but on on 7-inch tablets on portrait
mode it's almost like a phone but not
really and in landscape mode it's more
like a tablet but smaller so it's a kind
of a very big it's a kind of a gray area
type of device so it's an interesting
exercise in terms of design so what I
did with pattern was pretty much
blending the design of the tablet and
phones on portrait mode so you have a
one-column thing but you have the
sidebar yeah but on landscape you have a
more tablet like thing with a grid and
the sidebar while on phones you only
have one column and that's it and then i
use the sliding tabs to to give access
to different types of content we're like
sidebars and work
don't work well on phones anyway sir
yeah exactly this isn't in a hard place
yeah and and also i mean i'm not i'm not
really keen on the howdy college flight
fly out menu think we could the trails
where I infrared flying in menu or
something yeah yeah I'm i have my like
issues with it i think it's not this
girl discoverable it off it it's that's
one thing the other is it's kind of hard
to get it right you have to give it give
access to it everywhere or it feels with
google+ for example you have to be home
screen to have access to it so when you
click on the app button you never know
what's going to happen is it going to be
on the upper level or is it going to be
the flying menu so it's the same feeling
i got with a with a gingerbread type of
menus you have in android you know you
don't know what's going to happen you
don't know if the app menu is the same
thing you don't know if you slide from
the side will really see it or not like
say right if there's a bit of like
unpredictability it's just not that I
think you have to iterate this thing a
bit more to get it right because there's
a lot of implementations right now right
I'm going to recommend it to how many to
any one cycle at you I feel like it's
setting down still it hasn't really
Marcus might have some some thoughts on
this as well having implemented it it is
up but then yeah I feel like we're still
trying to work out what the right way to
do it is at the moment I think the
current feelings like the YouTube
applications for the best example of our
current yeah I agree where it's kind of
scene into the edge right credit
replacement for me to the dashboard it's
just accessed from somewhere else yeah I
don't know II it works well as a
dashboard but the thing is depending on
the type of that you
I expect it to be available everywhere
in the app no matter in what level of
navigation you are I think it's possible
if I does something like this you know
the flying menu is available everywhere
while in google plus it's not so yeah
there's a lot of work to some in terms
of like consolidating what how it's
supposed to behave so that you you
always have the same behavior that might
be it doesn't necessarily have to be
shouldn't be available everywhere I kind
of had I thought of that just ruins any
idea of hierarchy that you have true
true so I feel like it should only be
available from if you think of the
dashboard or the flattened and yourself
being the first level or the parent it
should only be available from direct
children of that my careful yeah the
only thing is maybe it's just a matter
of changing the icon or something but
because Google Plus right now has this
thing that looks like it's an up level
kind of thing but it's flying menu and
Spotify changes the icon to be something
like a menu looking kind of thing lady
that's it maybe it's just about giving
the hot the right tends to the user hmm
yeah I think that overloading the exact
same UI widget was perhaps a mistake the
ironic thing is that having that left
were pointing Chevron actually looks
more like it's intended for a fly-in
menu than it does for up my problem is
like if you think of the icon being up
it makes perfect sense like it's the top
level of your app and then you're going
down secret upper level to get to the
root of it it's just so I worried that
users don't think of it as up is it
likes left that's my G so this is kind
of perfect the concept of up for us to
222 you sir I went to Spotify by the way
we chose to use the new looking thing
like Facebook does it just is to make it
clear that this will show them and this
is something that is a lot that look
about the white way to do this and I'm
not really sure we didn't really want to
have an hi qualifier signal be using on
desktop it's much more on your browser
with exact import so kind of makes sense
to us to always have the mini available
five I know the at least from the
perspective of the Android UI designers
or UX designers are still kind of
there's still sort of coalescing on our
story with regards to these slide and
menus but but the stunts that I get is
that they're not going to go in the
direction of having it available
everywhere that they're going to
recommend restricting where it's
available from well of course it's kind
of intense based on what kind of
application making olds working so I'm
not saying it always should be out back
yeah I good for haitian a hierarchy to
music there right like you're a song
which is part of the playlist or an
album you know which is part of a list
of albums Elizabeth I feel like with the
implementation way I get your point
about jumping between different sections
but I feel like you lose the cost of
that as you lose that any kind of
structure which I think people feel a
strong attachment to structure people
instantly understand structure i think
it's how you know the real world works
and how we've been trying to think about
things for a long time so I feel like
going to lose that a little bit yeah but
you're kind of fun any lower case it's
kind of easy to do some part of apps
like always problems created to lightly
given other users playlist and going to
reduce your profile and so on on
care about to put everything into it
also get this problem that if we browse
around a lot and kind of easy to lose
your face I'm not able to go back to the
last where or it's kind of a tricky I
mean I'm not conquer sometimes were
holding a lot of browsing history which
you know huge had to keep on hitting the
back button a lot of times to you know
walk back along that record trail that
up is supposed to be hierarchy which you
know she'd never really be that deep oh
no well it's still kind of olive oil
yeah I think that the thing with it
depends on how you see that the flying
menu I one way to see it which I think
it's the case like it's out Spotify
implemented it's more like a jump list
instead of dashboard absolutely it's
pretty much about having a very fast
shortcut to go any to any of the roots
of navigation in the app instead of
working more like a dashboard I mean
there's a point about it the problem
with that is like I think the main
problem right now is there are too many
variations of the same pattern and so I
think the important thing is once you
consolidate that if it ever appears is a
facial API it should behave always the
same it shouldn't be like okay my app
works more like a champ Liz so let's do
the global thing oh no mine is more like
a dashboard play after that only it that
this would be very confusing yeah I
think people are pretty much an
agreement with with that sentiment but
because it is such a fresh new UI
feature that that that consensus hasn't
really gelled yet about how it's going
to be yeah
the issue is i see but but but i think i
totally agree it's pretty much an
ongoing it's something that's to
consolidating itself yeah but it
shouldn't take too long because i think
it's just spreading out quite quickly a
lot of people are thinking that this is
this is great let me do it and then
everyone does differently yeah and yeah
so I think it would be nice to
consolidate this as soon as possible I'm
sure we have you XD who looking at it
you need to get them to watch this watch
this video on they don't straightened
out lens I thought some duets people on
google i/o got a session about action
bars it was and they actually said they
were going to look at this first thing
of the dryer so hopefully a working on
it I was in the room I had that question
I got a big round of applause huh I was
not in the room but I saw the video yeah
Adam Powell the busiest man in android
so we move on from sliding drawers and
up navigation fingers it tends to
hijacker us maybe spend a moment or two
looking at W longest question about
phonegap joe says i don't know if you've
covered this before sorry if you have
but would you be able to give some
comments on the phone app framework as a
starting point for developer with three
to five years of PHP and java experience
do you guys want to want to take a crack
at this one or shall I hey I would say
you've got Java experience I would urge
you to look at native development yeah I
think having PHP in Java realistically I
think you're looking at phonegap stuff
you're going to be JavaScript heavy so
you'd actually probably be better off
going for the native fruit with a job
application and plus you'll get a better
experience at the end and usually be
more happy when the Dalai different Play
Store um and bus its analysis you're
never kind of having to wait to the
latest fee
just to be implemented phonegap
framework there's lots kind of a massive
pros by just gained on the native three
to be honest yeah I have a bunch of
problems with vendor apps I've never
seen one that I liked and I didn't think
could be applied a better experience if
done in native I think you get into the
uncanny valley trap where something that
looks like a button is actually you know
a link Mexican hang tag and you know
gets a funny highlight it doesn't have
the same touch response and it's
slightly slower to respond to I just
think when you're stacking abstractions
that on top of instructions on top of
abstractions you're going to lose
something you're going to lose the
responsiveness or the expectations of
what how a nap forms so well I can
understand the arguments for it like you
know from a speed of development or
cross that one button or whatever
argument I just think if you don't hate
your users and you should perhaps think
about going native it's the worst oh why
I will be the first to point out that
you are you are in front of a very
biased crowd area since all of us are
employed in the business of convincing
you to write the best application you
can using the native Android API s but
that's Ted I've also answered I've
answered this question in the past
couple of days in Stack Overflow and
everything that that Nick and matt said
I agree with in addition any of these
so-called cross-platform development
frameworks when you think about it it's
really a platform in its own right so
you know they claim to be right one to
run everywhere but all of the platforms
I sit on have their own little quirks
and you have to still chase down
platinum into implementing specific sort
of little hang-ups that appear so you
still basically have to write once and
test everywhere and now because you're
using a new platform that's sitting on
top of old platforms rather than having
to target your application to n
platforms you have to target it to n
plus 1 where the plus 1 is this
cross-platform framework that you're
supposed to be writing it in and then on
top of that there's also
you're stuck in the dilemma of either
you're writing to the least common
denominator across all the platforms
that you're deployed on or you're
accessing platform specific features on
the host platforms that you're sitting
on and losing your portability so one
way or the other there's not really it's
not really it it's not really a whim my
general recommendation is to abstract
out your business logic and make it as
portable as you can give your business
logic a clean API and then write the
best platform specific native UI that
you can and have your UI interface with
the API you defined in your core logic
yeah I mean one of the other things that
I'd say is I think I once is trying to
web developing you start looking in
phonegap he's quite excited about it
kind of showed me and I installed that
the kitchen sink app and I think we just
off the throw yer been released clicked
on the camera link opened up and it's a
new camera API and it just crashed
instantly and it's what I things if
you're going down that route and you're
relying on phonegap to do all of that
properly you have to then account for
the fact that doesn't work on certain
versions you've got to kind of wait the
update to be pushed whereas if you kind
of writing it yourself and I think you
get more flexibility around in tents etc
how you implement certain features so
yeah it's funny scenes it's whether you
take control of it or you hand it over
to another platform to another issue
entirely separate of course a fuller
question from mr. WL long I see mr. may
be wrong it says would you be able to
share some of the most significant
difficulties with dealing with barrett's
screen sizes and solutions to uh well we
have some great tutorials on just this
if you go to developer.android.com /
training there's one called was it
working with different screen sizes
managing different screen sizes and I
think the key to it is it is a state of
mind really is how you approach the dome
that you approach it a bit like a web
developer really you know that this
variation of screen sizes and
resolutions and density
so you don't go like deep down the whole
developing for just like you know the
cell phone in your pocket and then try
to retrofit kind of support other things
I think you approach it from a scaling
point of view sleeping you know this
thick and you know it should be at the
top then the stick and grow and in this
video's at the bottom or however you
might arrange it so very quickly a few a
few techniques you can do you say is
like using AG relative layouts things as
simple as that so you know they can fit
them grow and shrink until and always
work in density-independent pixels so
it's a concept and Android which and you
allows you to skip it to size things in
a way that it will appear the same
physical size across different density
screens that's really important and and
then to also think about providing
alternative layouts the different screen
sizes see and if you look at I think the
top blog post on Android developers blog
a moment I wrote about targeting about
getting a predator Nexus 7 and jelly
bean that talks about how you provide
alternative layouts for different
different devices depending on how much
space that have available to you so they
let you write an application with you
know one piece of logic behind it but on
different presentations yeah i think i
think i know that is just try and kind
of embrace the different buckets and you
can use of different beds pixels
adorable Sheltie ldpi MVP I cetera
because that doesn't just apply to draw
balls like Nick said it most layouts and
then values etc and then you can
literally extract more and more kind of
where those final value coming alert
system decide what's the most
appropriate value if you kind of embrace
that then you start getting a lot of
this done for free and you have to write
any additional code is that she handled
by just a simple XML file yeah use the
resources system yeah any tips or the
people on the call as well any top tips
and managing their variations in screen
sizes one thing that helped me a bit
with in pattern specifically needed to
kind of extreme approach but I think in
terms of fragments instead of activities
all the time yeah so I started with the
phone UI and what I started
it's a lot of activities with one
fragment inside most of the time but
then when I moved on to the tablet UI I
had all those compliments that I could
just assemble in different layouts so
that helped a lot so my tip would be
thinking like frag in terms of fragments
from the start so you can recombine
stuff later absolutely as a great plan
she said that so if you're not familiar
with fragments here w along they said
basically a reusable chunk of
functionality so you kind of write these
chunks and then you can have them laid
out in different very different
configurations definitely look at that
in fact if you take if you start to sign
from scratch on applications you take a
look at the new templates which we have
and in Eclipse then they'll create
fragments for you and so on so it's in a
great starting point now with with I
without writing any code yourself you
can get an application that has two
fragments on screen one of the list view
and another with a detail well on let's
have that funny device it will be a full
screen eek I think that's a that's quite
a step up from our old hello world
application I think so Marcus you have a
question incoming in the Google+
comments but your hand is asking how
spotify app manages to keep its service
running without showing up in the
running services list all aboard that's
what I but we also have a good are not
trying to update the wave work is ovah
will stay pushing a kid fact live with
doing something which means i download
music or play music there are few
conditions that can drop person like if
you 15 headphones and so on and if you
love to have a time evident remember
along this the bangle will actually shut
out the service and if we don't if
you're actually doing something it will
if you play music downloader you will
show a notification and thereby except
alive by the way if you're not too
particular again I think that's a good
tip you basically don't do any work you
don't need to do in your services make
sure you finish yourself if you if
you're not doing any work and perhaps in
a schedule that they don't leave the
service is running working for some
condition process might be run by also
under the assassin kid hmm but yeah so
we're actually want in half application
and separate process so that might be
like seems to go on so its aesthetic and
you're you're you're hiring processes
the service in you is different
processes yes and then you're talking to
each other with a IDL I have to have a
small question if there's still time
yeah I saw about robo juice released a
new version okay in fact destroy or
something and it looks really cool you
can like or eject beautiful resources
and all kind of stuff first one if
someone has actually try it out and
mouse it really works well not because
I'm kind of I kind of want to do it
other way two words but if it's blue
nice I not try it anyone have no I've
seen a couple of places people playing
around with it on google plus i'm really
liking it but yeah i'll tell that i play
with it myself yeah i think we've got
maybe one or two sample apps floating
around somewhere that that really the
engineers used juice to write them mom
pretty cool idea but done likewise i
also have not gotten into it myself yet
i went did something that i would
definitely keep in my back pocket us
something I might want to investigate
someone in the future they have some
sample apps being the critical story
looks really nice ice forming one day
Sena me mother but not gonna live with
myself I noticed that you know Gonzalez
was good enough to join us in a hangout
and he had a question in the moderator
we skimmed over pretty quickly but since
since he was good enough to join us here
I thought maybe we revisit that so he's
home you wanted to do you want to ask
your question yourself I think that
everything was righted so there's
there's no need to clarify Georgia but
well I can repeat the air that what he
was asking and well I start to doing
some development with the NFC api's for
the contactless smart cards and well the
first thing I've already published that
the issue is that i think that jellybean
is not supporting any ftp trance eve
always file i I published that issue it
wasn't common yet but I guess there is
that is an issue with jelly bean but and
the heb is completely dead for now it's
not possible to to talk with the tag and
well all the rest in the in the NFC
support and I think it's more oriented
for for the standard text for the end F
and not for for the technologies to talk
directly in raw format with the tech so
so the specialist documentation is is
not that good and i just lost a lot of
time and that was well actually i didn't
place any question my only question is
that if there was any book i could look
at because the because my issue for
example this morning was
to talk with the tag and installed my
facebook stall i'm not sure if my
pictures or not and i just lost entire
morning trying to talk in I great with
okay yeah I see the book in I great with
the tag and my conclusion is that the
stack just doesn't allow so yeah
probably i will take the suggestion and
try to look at that book and let you say
i think it is quite orientated around
doing and f yeah it's definitely because
we see as it's the most common use case
in this useful use case but you still
can do all the tech stuff like you still
can read the raw bytes and so on I guess
definitely supported use case well like
I was telling for example any of CVS is
completely dead in in jelly bean as far
at least on nexus s the ne se de so one
of the technologies for text is not
working I I I just fell out that tissue
a few days ago I used to work ah yes and
it's regress yeah my connection is
better i'm not getting it so I was just
asking it used to work on us come again
and its request but son sounds like a
baby every father well no idea because I
just started now with jelly bean and I
just have one phone but yeah and I
receive an exception saying something
not supported operation of well
technology not supported so I pretty
sure it's a regression because no one
was claiming that before you just yes
sounds sounds like a bug yeah it's for
sure
anisha I don't see ya so if you go to
source android com there'll be
instructions there on how to file a bug
so if you can file it as a bug that's
the right way to go to go ahead with
this yeah actually I think it well it's
on it's it's I guess it's this one just
well just a moment I think about already
how are you saying well it's like this
right on this this is my bag I filed
this is the correct place oh ok I
suppose it started yeah but this is the
the right place to define licious yep
it's not you yeah ok ok so it's just
that thanks for the the book suggestion
I i remembered worry i saw it i think i
think somebody in my google plus a
stream is the author of it and said hey
look i just published this book or
something like that day that's where i
might have seen it huh ok ok right yeah
very nice I think we've run out of time
so we started a little like a little
setup issue here but then thank you
everyone for joining us and and we'll be
back same time next week looks talking
Android development so until then you
know next week I will be in London and
we will all be involved in a developer
activity so you'll be interesting to
find out what shape the Hangout takes
maybe we can get some get some other
people on screen with us what do you
think yeah that's our stuff this is
philip only see two people well until
until next week yeah feel free to fire
questions it to the moderator and we can
take a look at them or a telling asleep
an awesome life ok thanks everyone for
coming cheers by one